Постріл!
Цей артилерійський підрозділ знаходиться за 10 кілометрів від росіян на Бахмутському напрямку.
Військові тут щоденно захищають піхоту і обстрілюють російські позиції, незважаючи на холод і… гризунів.
Їх чути швидше, ніж ви зможете їх побачити.
Миші гризуть усе - від пальців сплячих військових до комп’ютерних кабелів.
В епоху Starlink і сучасних технологій бійці все ще чекають на інновацію, щоб перемогти гризунів.
Та заважають працювати не лише миші, а й морози.
Ожеледиця ускладнює логістику, тому доставка боєприпасів відбувається повільніше.
Складно. Тому що морози, погода така, техніка ламається.
І якби... Ремонтувати теж не встигаємо швидко.
Під час літнього наступу військові змогли просунутися на ці позиції.
Вони збудували собі нові бліндажі, добре знаючи, що від цього залежатиме їхнє життя.
Просування було, ми стояли не тут, а...
Виходить, ми там далі стояли.
Ну, переїхали десь місяців десь два-три назад сюди.
Тобто вперед. Поки ще стоїмо, а там далі буде видно.
Зараз поки оборона, тому що вони зараз наступають.
І ми намагаємося відбити їхні напади.
Ну, якщо, допустимо, ми робимо на заборону там три-чотири, то вони можуть зробити і десять. І п'ятнадцять.
Цієї зими вони захищають свої позиції від російських військ, які намагаються їх повернути.
Російські дрони постійно полюють на техніку.
Оскільки вони і вдень, і вночі знаходяться в небі,
то цей український артилерійський підрозділ фактично живе під землею -
тоді, коли не веде вогонь по цілях.
Ну от, їхні пташки літають вдень, так само і вночі літають.
Якщо ми працюємо по якійсь цілі - з висоти все видно.
Видно виходи наші і вдень дим стоїть після пострілу - це все видно.
Якщо вони нас побачать - це вже нам, звісно, доведеться потім по бліндажах,
тому що вони починають обсипати.
І дронів у ворога все більшає, кажуть бійці.
Тут в основному що тут? ZALA, Орлан, КАБи, Ланцети.
Так само, спочатку, здається, і Ланцети, і Зала, і Орлани були, але їх не так багато було.
Зараз вони можуть отак пролітати. Пролітає в сторону.
Вони по парі літають - ZALA і Орлан. Або Ланцет.
Ну, вони пролетіли, за ними ще можуть пролетіти.
Тобто за день багато їх може. Вони чи кругами, я не знаю.
Ну намагаються, вишукують техніку.
Для того, щоб дати повноцінну відповідь росіянам -
треба більше людей і техніки, наголошують військові.
Якщо брати кількість їх і нас, то нас дуже мало.
Як не крути, нашої піхоти дуже мало. Та і техніки так само.
У них багато цього всього.
Допустимо, якщо нам дали сто одиниць техніки, то це добре.
У них, допустимо, тисяча одиниць техніки.
Тобто у них то більше, ніж у нас.
Ми з нашими ста і тримаємо позиції, і просуваємося вперед, як би тяжко не було.
А у них скільки техніки і у них не виходить.
Якби, допустимо, їхню техніку нам, то, я думаю, ми б їх давно вже вигнали звідси.
Кілька десятків чоловіків ховаються разом у землянці,
виритій на кілька метрів під мерзлою землею.
Супутниковий інтернет з’єднує їх із сім’ями.
Буває, рідним дзвониш, доньці: "Як у школі? ".
"Ну тат, сьогодні субота або неділя".
Ну, день бабака.
Якщо ти працюєш - ти тупо не знаєш, який день.
Частина бійців не змогла звикнути до постійних обстрілів і була змушена перейти в інші підрозділи.
Людина до всього може звикнути.
Просто щось складно вдається.
Хтось боїться, то...
Зрозуміло, що він не звикне до цього, якщо вона боїться сильно.
Цього всі бояться. Ну, є люди, які сильно.
У нас були просто такі, які боялися. І ми їх відправили.
Але тут не критикують тих, хто пішов.
Просто кажуть: ідеального солдата не існує і ніхто з них не народжений для війни.
Ми ж теж не вічні, правильно? Втрати є з усіх сторін.
Сидіти вдома і казати, там, "я хворий" або "я не народжений для війни"?
Немає ж такого, що мати родила тебе і каже: "О, все, буде служити".
Воювати доведеться усім, тому немає сенсу ховатися, кажуть військові.
Адже повномасштабна війна триває вже майже два роки.
Усьому навчають. І ти будеш вчитися, тому що, якщо ти не будеш вчитися, то...
Тут не пробачають помилок.
Можуть всі. У нас всі, хто там… були в одному підрозділі, приходять в інший. Вчаться дуже швидко.
Абсолютно. Ну, ми ж не всі з одним характером.
Ми всі різні. Але всі вчаться. Це твоє життя.
Якщо ти не будеш вчитися, то буде погано. Це у твоїх інтересах.
А дехто з них воює вже майже 10 років - ще з початку АТО.
У мене вже багато свят так пройшло.
Це наша робота - захищати людей.